komm und
[Musik]
mir ja ich bin wieder da Freunde ich bin
wieder da ich bin zurück Corona da dan
freuen sie sich ja
[Musik]
logisch sie gucken so traurig Siek g al
das jetzt wieder Überstunden machen muss
ne ich den an der
FC komm alle rein alle rein klein süßen
Räuber ich bin auch schon da wir haben
gleich richtig Spaß Zusam alle rein sind
krank Moment Moment wie
krank bin ich bin
Coronavirus ich habe dich schon mal vor
d jahrenastich schon
gehabt
super millionerkrankung jetzt aktuell
okay in Deutschland glauben sie dass
Köln das noch bis zum sessionsende
Reißen kann den Rekord bin ich überzeugt
von absolut auf Kölle auf wir schaffen
das
[Applaus]
K wünschen Sie sich auch die Zeit zurück
in der man an Karneval nur
Geschlechtskrankheiten bekommen
hat nein sie haben damit gar nichts zu
tun nein nein eh Corona oder eher
Geschlechtskrankheiten ach das ist mal
so mal so ne Virus hab ich aber keine
Angst weil ich kölch trinke ja dann ist
die richtige Einstellung geh doch weg
ist das so wenn man kölchink geht das
weg man muss long
Zein weiter ist kacke aber ich habe mehr
Angst dass das wir warm wird wenn
möchtest das aus mein kölchglas trinken
ja sehr gut ma ich wir trinken alle aus
dem gleichen Glas Leute scheiß drauf wir
viere kneval gen
richtig
ohne dich komme ich ganz gut an Dieck
stehen zu mir ohne die Bakterie bin ich
hier steck ich jetzt an ich steck sie
jetzt an sie steck ich an komm ih
ganz Bützchen sie geben mir jetzt
bütchen sie geben mir jetzt ein Bützchen
sie geben mir jetzt sofort ein btzchen
ich bin wieder
da
mm na ja genau ja ja die Zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
Symbole hier bei uns im neuen Studio
gefunden Illuminati Freimaurer staatsfun
ist alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben was er bei so vielen Abonnenten
auf
Youtube also ich würde mich ranhalten